dr. asthma most people when they think
about the future try to reach out to the
year 2000 let's try it 500 years from
now what kind of planet do you see one
of two depending on what happens by the
year 2000 if by the year 2000 we have
not solved the problems that face us
today then I would say 500 years we'll
see a world containing a technological
civilization in ruins in which there
will be a relatively small number of
human beings sort of surviving and with
New York City is the most magnificent
ruin in the history of the human race in
the other if we succeed if we succeed in
solving our problems today than 500
years now we can well be living in a
kind of utopia a world with a relatively
small population carefully husbanding
their resources with a working colony on
the moon and perhaps on Mars reaching
out to the entire solar system taking
advantage of advances in technology we
now can't even imagine living under
conditions which when they look back on
the present they will be horrified and
wonder how we could have survived
thank you dr. Asma
you